[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
habe gerade auf instagram der umfrage
gemacht und hab euch erzählt dass ich
die hochzeitstorte für meine freundin
für die lisa backen werde und diese
woche samstag ist es soweit am samstag
ist die hochzeit und ich werde eine
dreistöckige hochzeitstorte backen
dreistellig das einzige was mir bisher
schon überlegt habe die farben weiß ich
auch schon ein bisschen ich habe nur das
problem dass die hochzeit eben am
samstag ist und am freitag und am
donnerstag bin ich praktisch noch in der
anderen richtung ich bin nämlich
geschmack halten bei fieber habe dort
einen kinder pralinen kurs denn es ist
weltkindertag und da muss ich dann dort
vor ort sein werde mit den kindern lukat
pralinen machen und im prinzip muss ich
jetzt die torte so vorbereiten dass die
am samstag noch frisch ist das sehr
lecker ist dass sie gut aussieht und
heute zeige ich euch einfach also wer
geht jetzt einfach heute montag
chronologisch durch und ich werde euch
zeigen wie ich die torte plane backe und
hoffentlich am ende am samstag schönster
wäre sorgt das einzige was ich bisher
hat nur lisa war sie möchte eine torte
die habe ich hier natürlich
vorgeschlagen dass ich es packen und sie
hat mir hier dieses tablett gebracht das
hat die maße 40 mal 40 also die
innenmaße und starr witzigen die torte
darauf präsentieren und es wird so ein
bisschen vintage hochzeit so ein
bisschen mit blumen und dunkle rot
dunkelrot sind so die farben dazu mit
bild geschickt und ja ich bleibe jetzt
ja was ich nicht machen kann ist eine
frische torte mit frischen früchten und
quark sahne zum beispiel das wird sich
einfach nicht halten
also suche ich mir jetzt gleich noch
rezepte aus die praktisch durchziehen
müssen wie eine sache trotz zb die
einfach von tag zu tag immer besser wird
jetzt überlegt mir aber erstmal die
optik und ich habe mir gedacht ich setze
hier einen teller drauf da ist mir
allerdings noch zu klein das heißt
entweder finde ich jetzt noch auf die
schnelle eine tortenplatte die größe ist
so etwa 35 cm oder ich muss mir eine
selber bauen
das entscheide ich dann gleich noch die
hat jetzt nämlich 30
das ist definitiv zu klein ich glaube
ich glaube das wird zu klein und dann
bestelle ich heute noch die blumen bei
dem blumenladen wurde elisa eben auch
ihre blumen her habe ich mir gedacht
kann ich hier unten noch ein paar blumen
rein machen und jetzt zeige ich nicht
mehr erst mal die torte das ist immer so
der erste schritt ich habe eine vision
ich habe eine vorstellung habe ungefähr
eine idee wie die dort aussehen soll und
die zeichne ich jetzt mal also dann habe
ich jetzt hier das holzbrett und
irgendwas worauf die torte steht und die
erste torte wird die zweite machen wir
eckig und die oberwelt wiederholt
genauen maße überlege ich mir gleich
noch jedenfalls muss die untere etwas
größer werden
die farben sind also bisschen dunkel rot
weiß grün nicht gläubig dann machen wir
hier einfach mal hier so ein bisschen
blumen die muss ich bestellen da
mache ich denke hier noch was mit blumen
hin und natürlich hier unten
da muss ich halt einfach die mars ist
schon mal festlegen und kann es dann der
floristin sagen bei nacht jahr hatte ich
noch selber gebunden aber diesmal habe
ich keine zeit zum selber binden
also bestellte ich direkt bei der
floristin findet dann die blumen und
fertig hier oben drauf mache ich noch
die ornamente lisa und alex
und die bereit ich heute gleich zu die
müssen nämlich trocknen aus blüten
passte so ich würde sie alle mit von
dort dann halten sie sich auch länger
und bleiben schön saftig innen und hier
unten mache ich so marmor effekt hier
oben name und ich glaube das überlege
ich mir noch ich mach dich hier so ein
bisschen dunkelrot damit eine sehr
moderne selbst ob gott dann würde ich
hier weiße blumen
dann lege ich los dann mache ich hier
die deko lisa und alex das mache ich
jetzt aus blüten passte und dass wir
dann der rektor und beim kick hopper ist
im prinzip nur wichtig dass hier unten
an der stelle so ein bisschen eine
gerade fläche ist denn ich muss den
sektor aus blüten passte machen er muss
dann stabil stehen und ich will jetzt
kein zahnstocher sehen aber es muss
natürlich auf der torte befestigt werden
also kommt hier unten dann der
zahnstocher rhein ganz unsichtbar
der wird ihm die tochter gesteckt
eventuell sogar noch hier einen habe ich
mehr stabilität
ich erzählte blüten passte die habe ich
jetzt schon weiß geknetet und die hätte
richtig schön aus daher kann ich jetzt
damit in paper machen hier auf etwas
becker stärke ausrollen und schön
gleichmäßig und ich habe jetzt hier am
ausrollen starb diese fünf millimeter
scheiben
das heißt ich kann jetzt so aus und dann
wird die platte 5 mm dick
[Musik]
so soll die schablone ausschneiden
und jetzt mit etwas kokosöl einreiben
die schablone auflegen und dann
ausschneiden
[Musik]
okay die buchstaben haben wir jetzt doch
nicht so gut gefallen ich lasse jetzt
erst mal liegen und macht mit orte
wieder weiter bevor ich jetzt die torte
backen muss ich jetzt schon mal
überlegen wie groß soll sie denn
überhaupt werden
das hier ist die tortenplatte eine
tortenplatte also eine etagere habe ich
noch nicht das muss ich wahrscheinlich
bauen
ich will aber dass die unsere tochter 35
cm groß wird also nehme ich mal mein
kickboards diese gläser und kann es
schon ein bisschen einmal andeuten
ich denke dass wir das untere stockwerk
und die torte doch schon groß und
mächtig sein ist eine hochzeitstorte
dann hätte ich ja gerne eine eckige
torte zwischen so ein achteck da zeige
ich gleich noch wie ich das hoffentlich
achteckig zugeschnitten bekomme das man
haben jetzt mag so und auch schön hoch
das wäre dann so die eckige torte und
dann glaube ich passt es mit 20 cm auch
ganz gut nicht auffangen
und ich glaube ich glaube dass hier gut
aus auch mal ein bisschen
vorstellungskraft dir und die achteckige
ich dir und oben eventuell noch die deko
die mir momentan leider noch nicht
gefällt ich muss mal schauen wie ich die
weitermache
ok also das machen wir so also ich backe
der 35 cm torte ich muss gucken ob
dieser film tortenring geht und mit 20
cm und dann noch eine mit 30 und die
wird da noch zugeschnitten
ok los geht's ans rezepte suchen ich
muss jetzt rezepte machen die im prinzip
bis samstag halten und schön durchziehen
[Musik]
also eins muss ich euch sagen gestern
waren nicht mein tag ich glaube heute
startet jetzt erstmal mit den böden
ich musste mir noch einmal die maße
überlegen und zwar mache ich die untere
torte 30 denn mein blick hat er nur 32
also gucke ich jetzt einfach wie weit
ich den tortenring groß machen kann
das wären jetzt 30 und ich glaube das
passt auch später bei der unteren da
mach ich dann die aprikosen jetzt mache
ich erstmal die mittlere torte
das wird die acht orte und dafür nehme
ich dann weil ich jetzt auch ein
kleineres maas habe diese platte hier
die hard 26 cm
das heißt ich mache jetzt erstmal ein
kreuz drauf dass jetzt eine garage bord
und ich nehme einfach einen stifter
immer wieder abwischen kann
ich habe ich jetzt acht gleiche
kuchenstücke und hier oben muss ich die
dann nur noch verbinden und dann habe
ich das achteck
und habe ich praktisch immer einen 45
grad winkel und dann ist es wirklich
perfekt das jetzt also einen durchmesser
von 26 cm
da habe ich am wenigsten verschnitt und
diese platte werde ich später aus holz
zu schneiden dann habe ich zwei holz 8
ecke und die brauche ich dann eben zum
füllen der torte jetzt kann ich hier
erst mal den teig machen da mache ich
jetzt dunkle sacher böden und ich habe
ich schon alle zutaten werden ist es
natürlich nacheinander backen für böden
insgesamt und in einem rezept könnt ihr
schon mal alles schritt für schritt
nachschauen
also ich brauche jetzt zuerst der mutter
bruder zucker schokolade etwas
tonkabohnen extrakt zucker eiweiß und
gelb das sind die zutaten für einen
boden und ich werde hier in der rhön
schiffe die butter mit dem zucker
verrühren kann in der zwischenzeit
schade schokolade schmelzen so
unterzuckerung tonkabohne
so schön verrühren und in der
zwischenzeit eiweiß salz und zucker
steif schlagen
den eigenen nicht zu schweifen also das
darf ruhig noch so ein bisschen so wie
so flapsig aus dem schloss sich nicht
ganz fest dass nämlich besser
das heißt arbeite ich ein bisschen
parallel damit ich einfach schneller
fertig bin
das wichtigste beim hochzeitstorten
bakker ist macht euch einen plan damit
ihr einfach nicht durcheinander kommt
vergesst keine zutaten nichts
überstürzen alles schön langsam zu
bereiten
ich finds echt mal ganz gut wenn man
sich vorher alles abwägt und hinstellt
dann weiß ich da zumindest schon mal ich
bin konzentriert dabei habe alles bereit
und kann keine zutat vergessen
der erste kann schon mal in den ofen die
anderen werde ich jetzt parallel zu
bereiten alle nacheinander backen oder
geht's direkt mit dem nächsten boden
weiter
da es ist das gute stück das ist jetzt
der zweite der schon fertig ist der
dritte papst auch schon den muss ich nur
noch stellen
ok den kuchen lasse ich jetzt hier kurz
stehen denn erst da habe ich schon
gestürzt einfach auf einem küchentuch
auf ein sauberes mit einem abkühlen geht
darunter so wird der boden nämlich schön
gerade jetzt mache ich gerade noch die
nächsten böten das werden jetzt die
kleinen die 20er und die habe ich jetzt
auf 19,5 eingestellt damit ich später
mit dem garching bord alles schön gerade
bekomme hier mache ich jetzt meine helle
sachertorte da findet ihr das rezept
dann auch bei mir auf dem blog ist es
übrigens ein rezept aus meinem neuen
buch also ist im prinzip so ein bisschen
das rezept verraten ich hier mache ich
nämlich weiße schokolade dran vorfälle
böden und ab hier ist auch schon butter
mit puderzucker verrührt die eigelbe
rhein und die weiße schokolade dann auch
hier das mehl dazugeben und das mache
ich dann immer einfach so mit dem
schneebesen dann noch das übrige mir und
dann etwas milch oder likör zum beispiel
zufügen und dann den eischnee wieder
vorsichtig unterheben haben kein echtes
fitnessstudios sparen
ich habe jetzt schon muskelkater und ich
hab noch nicht mal von hand geknetet
aufgaben echte hilfe holen da habe ich
die jungs aus dem büro mir egal
dann müssen sie nicht schneiden sondern
durch mit mehr von hand kneten die
weichmacher
das ist jetzt direkt die menge für und
das ist jetzt direkt die menge für 2
back ringe und da passen auch zwei auf
ein blech das ist echt perfekt davon
mache ich auch insgesamt 4
kleiner zwischenstand nach zweieinhalb
stunden die vier schoko böden sind
fertig einer ist hier hinten die 32 sind
da einer ist noch drüben im backofen
die zwei hellen sind auch schon im
backofen die zwei nächsten hinkommen
gerade noch dazu jetzt muss ich eine
kleine pause machen denn die banken sind
einfach alle blockiert die torten ringe
sind blockiert und mein werkzeug geht
mir aus dass ich schaue jetzt die
schiene ein kann in der zeit gleich noch
mal die decke hoch vorbereiten die mir
gestern nicht so gut gefallen hat dieses
l und a und dann geht's weiter mit dem
aprikosen machen
weiter geht es mit dem man sonntag der
wird jetzt der größte boden also der
30er eingestellt habe ich den tortenring
schon das rezept findet ihr auch auf
meinem blog ohne ich bei den verfeinern
mit etwas getan mandl aroma- und das ist
echt super lecker amaretto könnt ihr
auch nehmen aber amaretto rist mit
alkohol und das wäre praktisch einfach
nur das extrakt so einfach nach
anleitung zubereiten
das hörten block und den mache ich jetzt
auch drei oder viermal ich guck mal ich
mach jetzt mal den ersten schiebt den in
den ofen und dann sehe ich ja wie groß
der wird und wie hoch der wird vor allem
und dann kann ich immer noch entscheiden
ob drei oder vier
aber ich mag es meist so ich mag lieber
einen kuchen mehr und fred ihn lieber
zur not ein wenig init brauche wenn ich
nämlich dann nochmal backen muss dann
bin ich halt echt dem zeitverzug
bei diesem tag rezept werden die eier
mit dem zucker salz und bittermandel
aroma sehr schaumig gerührt danach höre
ich das öl mit der buttermilch 1
und zum schluss kommen die mandeln das
mehl und backpulver dazu und werden nur
noch ganz kurz eingerührt also die menge
mit 6 1 für eine 60 köpfige sieben eier
und daraus die zutaten ist es nicht
gehen da sage noch mal einer backen mehr
frauen arbeitet das ist voll die
männerarbeit weiß ich warum die meisten
konditoren männer sind sie nämlich stark
aber wir frauen nummer zwei ist jetzt
auch so weit so ich muss mir das so
abgewinnen kann das bei uns stellen
jetzt gucke ich einfach mal wie die zwei
backen und dann kommt eventuell noch der
dritte dazu und dann kann ich jetzt
wieder bisher klar schiff machen und die
decke habe ich immer so nett gemacht ihr
seht es kommt immer dazwischen
aber das sollte ich mich jetzt doch
vielleicht kurzen einsatz denn es muss
ja noch alles durch trocknen die blüten
passte
die blüten passte rolle ich jetzt zu
einem langen strang daraus form ich
jetzt die buchstaben so sehen sie
einfach ein bisschen dreidimensionaler
aus
[Musik]
die sachertorte die werde ich fühlen mit
einer schoko buttercreme mache aber auch
noch mal laden rein das war schön saftig
wird und auch durchziehen kann dies am
samstag die schoko buttercreme dass es
die französische buttercreme da gibt es
auch das rezept auf meinem blog und ich
werde noch mit dunkler ganache machen
die brauche ich dann zum bestreichen
also die sahne die kocht gleich die darf
ich nicht vergessen die schokolade für
die buttercreme ist schon geschmolzen
die mutter werde ich hier weich berühren
und damit ich keine rohen eier in der
buttercreme habe und sehen natürlich
auch länger hält werde jetzt die eier
die gemeinsam mit dem zucker und etwas
salz erhitzen auf 70 grad für zehn
minuten so sind alle keime abgetötet
nebenher noch die ganz fertig stellen
die kamera ist auch nicht fertig und die
lasse ich dann abgedeckt über nacht hier
stehen bei raumtemperatur und schaut mal
wenn man die schokolade reibt dann ist
sie lediglich in sekundenschnelle fertig
die ist gut und die eier weil ich jetzt
wie gesagt erhitzen dann ist die
buttercreme länger haltbar und dann wird
alles noch mal bestimmt
wenn ihr keine küchenmaschine mit ihrer
funktion hat könnt ihr das ganze auch
einfach aufhört machen über dem
wasserbad und guck mal die maschine hat
jetzt herunter geschaltet
das ist die sicherheitsfunktion bei 60
grad und dann muss ich hier auf den
temperatur knopf drücken und einfach
bestätigen dass ich dabei bin
das ist einfach falsch kinder in der
küche sind und den knopf hochdrehen dass
einfach nichts heiße frau starb das
opfer war mit sicherheit und wenn die
temperatur hier dann gleich 70 grad
anzeigt ab dann drehe ich die zehn
minuten also mindestens zehn minuten
kommen kann mit rein
[Musik]
die sache böten habe ich jetzt alle
schon durchgeschnitten mit einer torte
säge und die lassen sich echt perfekt
durchschneiden die buttercreme dahin
habe ich die butter schon weich gerührt
hier kühlt jetzt gerade noch die eier
creme ab das heißt nach zehn minuten die
hitze wegnehmen die eier muster vom
wasserbad herunternehmen und schön kalt
rühren die schokolade steht da auch noch
und hier habe ich bereits in einem topf
ein bisschen aprikosenmarmelade erwärmt
das ist die selbstgemachte aus dem
garten und wenn ihr möchtet dann könnt
ihr da zum beispiel auch ein bisschen
likör dazu geben oder zum beispiel etwas
rum und die böden damit trinken und ich
bestreite jetzt hier so werden sie schön
saftig wenn die sind schön saftig aber
so kommt noch mal so ein fruchtiger
touch mit rein und sie bleiben dann eben
auch mehrere tage saftig streiche ich
alle und lasst sie kurz einziehen
[Musik]
für die schoko buttercreme werden jetzt
einfach alle zutaten verrührt also
flüssige schokolade die abgekühlte masse
und die butter
[Musik]
perfekte konsistenz und jetzt wird die
torte so gefüllt immer so ein bisschen
buttercreme dazwischen schön glatt
verstreichen und den nächsten boden
aufsetzen und das mache ich jetzt so
weit bis mir die höhe der torte gefährt
falls die torte hier zu instabil wird
weil die creme noch zu weich ist kannst
du die torte zwischendrin auch immer mal
gerne kühlen damit die butter festwirt
achte einfach drauf dass sie immer schön
glatt gestrichen wird damit sie eben
nicht schief wird
die buttercreme hat jetzt perfekt
gereicht und ich lasse ziert diese drei
böden übrig ich mach's doch generell
immer so der boden der ganz oben war
nicht ganz so eben ist den dass ich
immer erst mal raus einen habe ich hier
unten mit drin
ich möchte jetzt einfach dass es eine
schöne hohe hochzeitstorte wird und der
abschluss hier oben immer erst mal noch
mal gucken ob alles gerade ist und der
abschluss ist immer der boden des
schönsten [ __ ] bodens dann hab ich
nämlich noch schöne gerade fläche kann
hier noch einen trotten retter
drauflegen und mit orten waage
kontrollieren ob die torte im wasser ist
und dann kann die schon mal so wie sie
ist in den kühlschrank
ich werde erstmal so rein stellen für
eine halbe stunde bis stunde bis sie
fest ist und dann packe ich sie ein
bisschen mit frischhaltefolie ein damit
sehr einfach nicht austrocknet ich habe
ja nicht so eine grosse totenglocke
glocke flotte glocke totenglocke
heute bin ich schon ziemlich erschöpft
dass es wie beim bau der rohbau der
steht noch nicht dass torten gerüst
steht noch nicht und im prinzip steht
mir noch das größte bevor nämlich die
deko jetzt habe ich hier die kleinen
tortenböden aufgeschnitten und
normalerweise wollte ich die nur mit
marmelade bestreichen wie so eine helle
sachertorte
aber dann wird sie mir einfach zu flach
also habe ich mir jetzt gedacht tue ich
jetzt noch in bern auf und macht eine
himbeere buttercreme die halten sie doch
echt gut das heißt heute ist was ist
heute für ein wochentag dienstag bis
samstag hält sie sich ganz gut die
buttercreme wird mit den hintern gemacht
die werde ich jetzt hier einfach ein
kochen und dann die gleiche buttercreme
machen wie beim schoko boden also eier
mit zucker verrühren oder dazu und die
eingedeckten himbeeren dazu und dann das
ganze fülle
[Musik]
hier erwärme ich jetzt noch parallel
etwas himbeermarmelade zum bestreichen
der böden
[Musik]
die himbeeren die kochen jetzt gerade
noch ein ist ein bisschen dürfen sie
noch ein ticket also bis fast wirklich
keine flüssigkeit mehr da ist und ich
kann jetzt schon mal die füllung machen
für den untersten boden da mache ich
jetzt auch keine aprikosen marzipantorte
sondern eine kirsch marzipantorte ich
habe ziel bereits 1,5 kilo kirschen aus
dem tiefkühlfach auftauen lassen und
würde jetzt hier etwas wasser und stärke
ihr könnt auch wenn er es aufbauen last
und kaltenkirchen auch hier schafft
nehmen womit der stärke verrühren
so ein bisschen klümpchen frei ich
brauche noch ein bisschen wasser
und das lasse ich jetzt hier gleich
eindecken ja sowieso eine art pudding es
ist auch ein bisschen beeilen denn das
ist schon spät geworden
schon kurz nach 17 uhr glaub ich kurz
nach 17 uhr
und ich will auch heute irgendwann
vorhaben also dass jetzt ein bisschen
kochen lassen und dann kommt da noch
marzipan mit rein und da nehme ich jetzt
von unserem freund von sven dieses very
cherry marzipan automatik haben mit
kirche hat es eine tolle farbe direkt
aus berlin hat noch ganz viele andere
geschmacksrichtungen amaretto pistazie
sandsturm und noch ganz viele weitere
also für jeden geschmack etwas dabei
was für eine schöne farbe und die
bekommt man halt echt nur wenn man vorne
kirche nimmt und ich die aus dem glas
und jetzt kommt hier das marzipan rhein
in stückchen und dann kann ich die masse
pürieren und abkühlen lassen über nacht
und damit gesamt die unterschied orte
geführt
das habe ich so noch nie gemacht aber
probleme zusammen aus
[Musik]
die master noch dazu
die abgekühlten himbeeren frühere ich
jetzt mit der butter masse wenn ihr den
himbeergeschmack minimal noch verstecken
wollte dann etwas
der extrakt liebe aber und da kann ich
jetzt die torte film auch über nacht
kühl stellen
und da geht es morgen weiter heute
gleich acht ist 18 uhr schon vorbei 18
uhr ist schon vorbei
neuer tag neues glück ich bin schon
wieder ganz fleißig hier die böden sind
jetzt auch schön durch gekühlt über
nacht habe ich es einfach abgedeckt hier
rühre ich nochmal ne buttercreme da ist
die mutter
da ist die eier maße denn auf dem
unteren kuchen werde ich jetzt doch mit
buttercreme füllung
ansonsten ist mir das einfach ich bin
eine torte muss halt eine torte seien
mit creme die hier die es jetzt auch
schon abgekühlt ist seht schön fest
geworden das heißt es werde ich dann als
füllung nehmen schreitet hier erstmal
die böden durch und ich hab noch einen
tipp für euch genau deswegen habe ich
jetzt im prinzip ist die kamera
gestartet denn hin habe ich die eier
creme die habe ich erhitzt auch zehn
minuten elf habe ich sogar gemacht und
jetzt wird sie kalt gerührt und zum
calvin werde ich jetzt einfach um roh
füllen
zurück geht es nämlich ein bisschen
schneller und habe ich praktisch eine
kalte schlüssel fürs rein und dann müsst
ihr nicht 20 minuten rühren sondern es
verkürzt sich auf etwa zehn ja- zu
machen was jetzt kommt mal wie lecker
aber ist eben viel zu warm weil er hier
unten auch die induktionsplatte ist also
nehmen als die kalte schüssel sallys
schnell back tipps
[Musik]
naja masters fühlen
ich hatte hier auch ein kühl fed drin
damit einfach schneller geht und die wir
jetzt in die butter masse angerührt
schön langsam und weil sie jetzt eine
amarena kirsch torte wird gebe ich jetzt
hier noch bittermandel aroma dazu
theoretisch könnte tier aber auch hier
amaretto dazu geben einfach direkt in
die eier musste mit rein beim erhitzen
[Musik]
die batterie ist radio ein sorry ich
springe wir uns aber amerikanische jetzt
wird die torte gefüllt das heißt ich
nehme dann immer so ein klecks von der
amarena kirsch füllung mit marzipan
verstreiche die obstsalat versteht sich
die torte jung unter geschubst ich nehme
immer gern zwischen schotten platte und
torten drehteller eine antirutschmatten
darüber kommt dann eine schicht
buttercreme und so wird die torte wieder
geschichte und ich schau dann wieder
nach der höhe eventuell lasse ich den
boden weg oder machen doch noch drauf da
schaue ich mal jetzt haut mit dürfen ja
mich sagt schön hoch werden ich könnte
jetzt echt einfach rein weißen gut
gestern habe ich bisher gelebt probe
sich gestern gelassen
die war echt gut und das könnte jetzt
auch theoretisch in die buttercreme
reinfall
also so vermischen aber ich finds so
zweifel habe ich schon und ich nehme
jetzt zwei verschiedene paletten so
bleibt die weiße cremeweiß und das rote
drunter
das einmaleins des praktisch sozusagen
[Musik]
letzter boden ich lasse es den einen weg
da ist nämlich nicht ganz so schön den
laster ist mir auch das letzte spiel
gebacken aber dafür nehme ich jetzt hier
noch den letzten und wie gesagt da nehme
ich immer den boden weil der schön
gerade ist perfekt und dann kontrolliere
ich jetzt auch gleich wieder ob die
torte schön gerade ist dann kommt in den
kühlschrank und während die hier kühlt
kann ich schon mal die anderen zu
schneiden und mit ghanas bestreichen die
garage habe ich gestern auch schon
hergestellt weiß und dunkel an zu
zittern jetzt etwas das grundgerüst
steht der rohbau ist fertig jetzt kommt
der estrich drang das wasser berichteten
[Musik]
ich hatte jetzt ja die torte über nacht
im kühlschrank
ich hab sie im dax papier eingeschlagen
und schottenring drumherum gesetzt und
abgedeckt perfekt jetzt wird sie
zugeschnitten denn diese torte möchte
ich achteckig haben also nehme ich jetzt
hier im mai blech setzt es so ein
bisschen hin
die platte ist da ganz cool und ich habe
diese schablone gemacht und hier das
holz zugeschnitten einmal für oben
einmal für unmut dass für unsere brauche
ich jetzt erstmal noch nicht drauflegen
sitzt perfekt und die torte ist jetzt
minimal kleiner als das holz das gehört
aber auch so und jetzt hier einfach die
seiten wegschneiden und darauf achten
dass sie wirklich gerade unter schneidet
und es ist doch einfacher diese platte
hier auch noch unten dann zu machen dann
habe ich nämlich da auch die
schnittkante wo ist die schwer und ich
haben uns gedacht
und hier kann ich jetzt noch mal
kontrollieren ob es wirklich
übereinander sitzt deswegen schneide ich
jetzt auch erstmal die gegenüberliegende
seite an seinem körper abspielt
[Musik]
ich schneide es jetzt hier auch so dass
es so leicht hinter der kante ist damit
ich eine kante habe um die garage gleich
blatt zu streichen
also immer den kuchen minimal kleiner
schneiden
so sieht wirklich gut aus ich brauche
jetzt noch eine dünne platte wo ich
praktisch die torte drauflegen kann und
die dann noch unter der torte bleibt
dafür ist mit die zu dick daher nehme
ich jetzt noch eine dünnere holzplatte
ihr könnt auch eine leicht schon platte
nehmen oder ein kickboard einfach zu
schneiden und das sage ich nicht nur
kurz an und schneidet dann in der
werkstatt zu
[Musik]
perfekt noch ein bisschen schleifen und
dann geht es wieder an die torte
[Musik]
auf die saubere platte streiche ich
jetzt etwas ganache so bleibt die torte
schön daran haften
und da nehme ich die torte ein dickes
brett
dann kommt jetzt die dunkle gar an den
rand und diese platten bewirken jetzt
dass ich die richtig schön platt
hinbekomme erstmalig eine dünne schicht
so dass die krügel gebunden werden die
krümel vom kuchen und dann kommt die in
den kühlschrank und dann nach dem fest
werden kann ich sie dann ganz glatt
streichen
ich arbeite jetzt einfach gleich
parallel an allen trocken
so speichern immer ein bisschen
wartezeit
der torte mache ich sie zu ich nehm
jetzt die gagen boards die 20 er setzt
eine nach unten
und hier kann ich jetzt auch mit hilfe
der garagen boards die torte schönen
glattstreichen wieder zuerst die erste
schickt die krümel schicht und später
dann komplett klappt jetzt hier erst mal
grob alles abdecken
[Musik]
bei der großmutter brauche ich jetzt
noch die buttercreme auf die noch übrig
habe und die wir dann auch komplett
gestrichen
danach mit der ghanas bestrichen und
hier nehme ich dann die 30 garagen
boards und da werde ich später alle
torten nacheinander bestreiten
das wird jetzt noch mal eine große
arbeit und das ist so ein part der ist
wirklich ganz wichtig wie beim verfassen
des hauses bevor die tapete drauf kommt
muss natürlich die wand stellen glatt
sein denn wenn ihr löcher darunter habt
oder unebenheiten sieht man das später
unter dem von dort also jetzt wirklich
noch mal richtig viel mühe geben beim
glattstreichen alles perfekt machen und
die deko danach das ist dann so der
kleinste partner noch bleibt
[Musik]
die torte für eine stunde im kühlschrank
und jetzt streiche ich hier außen die
ganz großzügig auch einfach hier
zwischen den platten
das ist immer so ein kurz ein bisschen
fest werden und zwar einfach direkt 23
seiten bestreichen
h die spülmaschine ist jetzt auf fertig
hast du das gemacht
und dann die große zeit hatte ansetzen
und schön glatt abziehen
und hier ist jetzt erst mal wichtig den
überschuss wegzubekommen dass die torte
wirklich schön gerade ist und wenn dann
noch lücken sind völlig sie mit etwas
ganz auf und sie nochmal ab und da habt
ihr wirklich perfekte seiten perfekt
perfekt
mein mandant ist aber wir können heute
von bernd arbeiten endlich auch stellt
einfach danke ich habe ich darauf
gewartet ich wollte auch den murat
vorbeischicken
aber wenn man erstmals lieber wenn du
gekommen bist danke mit eine eckige
torte eine achteckige torte wird die
hochzeit grund kann jeder
ich finde sie bisher so schön und jetzt
habe ich jetzt diese dünne platte das
ist der boden das heißt die torte darf
jetzt gedreht werden und mit hilfe
dieser zwei platten bekommt ihr sie
wirklich perfekt klappt also so kriegt
man es ohne die platten echt nicht hin
auch nicht mit viel anstrengung jetzt
die obere wegnehmen die hatte ich ja
nicht angeklebt da war keine kameras
darunter trotzdem sehr vorsichtig die
seite muss ein bisschen ausgleichen aber
wirklich minimal hier streiche ich jetzt
noch mal die gage auf die habe ich ein
bisschen weich gemacht strich sie glatt
und dann kommt die torte in den
kühlschrank und ist bereit für den front
doch das ist verrückt wenn ich so eine
glatt gestrichene torte glücklich mal so
schön perfekt glatt gestrichene torte
[Musik]
seht ihr diese glücksgefühle genießt
kraftvoll diese stille und diese torte
ich genieße den moment
torte ein ist glatt valley ist glücklich
die zeit sagt ich muss mich beeilen
hier sitze ich jetzt ein 20 cm jackpot
auf und stürzt die torte dann das zweite
garagen bord kann ich jetzt auch
entfernen und die torte komplett glätten
dann ist sie nämlich bereit für den vom
dorf
[Musik]
die acht orte ist jetzt schon schön
glatt die weißen torten die kühlen
gerade noch da mache ich noch die letzte
schicht drauf die achttägige torte wird
dunkel
ich habe mir gedacht die untere und die
obere werden weiß marmoriert und die
mittlere wird dunkel so dunkle rot wie
die blumen die die leser auf der
hochzeit haben wird also nehme ich jetzt
hier roten von dort und etwas schwarz
ich nehme mal vier päckchen rot und mich
mir einfach ein bisschen schwarz dazu
und werden von der schön weiß werde ich
mit kokosfett beschichteten händen
kneten und da ist echt genial denn da
ist kein palmfett drin sondern wirklich
nur shea butter und dadurch wieder
richtig schön strapazierfähig er lasst
mir schon reist nicht
ich habe es insgesamt sechs päckchen
roth genommen und was ein ganzes
päckchen schwarz also ein bisschen
weniger etwa 200 gramm
die farbe ist jetzt richtig schön sie zu
dunkel auf aber das passt und den von
dort werde ich jetzt auf etwas becker
stärke ausrollen und dann die torte
einkleiden
ich mache hier auch immer lieber ein
bisschen mehr von damals zu wenig denn
noch mal die farbe nach mission ist echt
schwierig und wenn ich was ich habe kann
ich es einfach luft nicht aufbewahren
findet die nächste trotte zum ausrollen
nämlich übrigens immer keinen
puderzucker den puderzucker hinterlässt
spuren und da muss man es mit wasser
wegwischen
und da wird davon nicht schön daher
wirklich immer auch bäcker steige
zurückgreifen das ist eine reine
doppelstärke und die kann man dann
einfach wieder wegwischen oder mit dem
pinsel ab oder kleine luftblasen könnt
ihr einfach mit einem kleinen scharfen
kater aufschneiden und wegwischen becker
stärke hat den vorteil dass man sie
spurlos wieder entfernen kann entweder
mit einem pinsel oder mit einem sauberen
tuch
jetzt wird die torte mit back trend
spray für strichen bzw besprüht damit er
von dorschen haften kann
jetzt hier immer schön zuerst die ecken
glätten und nach unten hin denn von dort
weg streichen
damit eben auch die falten verschwinden
[Musik]
ach decken sind schon viele ecken an
seiner torte man auf die idee mit den
acht ecken einer viereckigen torte hat
man schon das problem mit den vier ecken
acht ecken das toppt hat jetzt alles
[Musik]
seit mein gott ich werde mir verschluss
der hand gerutscht
das heißt so upside down funktioniert
das jetzt nämlich besser denn ich kann
zum einen die ecke hier glätten und nach
unten hin noch scheinen glattstreichen
[Musik]
die stunde der wahrheit wenn ich schön
gearbeitet habe habe ich jetzt eine
schöne achteckige torte dich nicht
fallen lassen und werde nicht die kante
kaputt machen
da kommt noch gold strüber ich finde sie
gut ich stelle jetzt in den kühlschrank
die darf jetzt nicht abgedeckt werden
damit er von dornick schwitzt das heißt
die torte hat jetzt den schutzmantel mit
dem von dort der schützt die torte jetzt
bis samstag die anderen beiden torten
werde ich jetzt einpacken in folie bzw
einen tortenring abdecken
die rechtlich erst am samstag über zehn
denn wir müssen jetzt gleich nach
schmalkalden fahren und ich kann jetzt
die hochzeitstorte erstmal nicht
weitermachen
das einzige was noch machen werde ist
die deko das a und l und das unh zeichen
noch mit gold besprühen
damit ist auch schon abtrocknen kann ja
und dann muss ich den rest dort machen
pralinen werde ich dort noch herstellen
und dann gucken wir mal ob ich alles
fertig kriegen sonst
nach dem trocknen werden sie dann mit
lebensmittel metallic farbe gesprüht
auf der vorder und auf der rückseite und
dann las ich die kriegsopfer komplett
trocken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es brauche ich noch ein paar zutaten und
pralinen herzustellen
deswegen bin ich hier in der fiba welt
hier werde ich morgen einem thema berlin
kurs machen
und jetzt gibt es aber schon mal ein
paar pralinen rezepte für euch dafür
brauche ich jetzt erstmal lukas und
schokolade
[Musik]
[Applaus]
homophobie schokolade
sony war für dich nur das beste
und heute lecker sind die perlen
und hier gibt es an der theke die
handgemachten pralinen da habe ich mir
auch welche abgeschaut und gesagt okay
die und gegen die würde ich gern machen
sie betreffen zum beispiel machen wir
hier die pure hohn treffen die werden
wir machen und die kann man sich hier
holen und wirklich alle werden
handgemacht oben in der confiserie und
da gehen wir heute zu unserer eigenen
pralinen
er lade bis jetzt meine hochzeit
beauftragte für lisas hochzeit machen
wir jetzt pralinen ok kannst mir helfen
ganz viele parallelen zu machen
okay wir machen jetzt pralinen die erste
sorte sind mondäpfel dafür verwenden wir
weiße hohlkörper ich brauche 255 gramm
weiße schokolade 90 gramm kondensmilch
oder same 21 gramm oder andere zutaten
und eine prise vanille damit die
schokolade schon geschmolzen temperiert
muss sie nicht werden denn es ist ja
guck mal die kondensmilch damals auch
schon geschmolzen beziehungsweise warm
gemacht
ok jetzt mischen wird das ja das ist
nicht kalt ist jetzt alles schön war und
ist es jetzt hier auch da magst du rein
giessen ok dann diesmal
im prinzip wird jetzt hier nur mit der
marshall gestellt da könnt ihr auch
sahne nehmen und einfach die schokolade
menschen mit der sahne oder mit der
kondensmilch vermischen
in der confiserie nimmt man von grenzen
hielt einfach wegen der haltbarkeit gut
dort die nehmen für die hat den löffel
nicht mehr den jetzt darfst du das ganz
langsam ganz langsam verrühren
wer mit unserer wandel exakt vergessen
deswegen der gemahlene vanille
das ist auch lecker jetzt darfst du den
mond dazugeben und an der stelle da kann
man jetzt natürlich auch den mohn
weglassen oder andere zutaten dazugeben
wieder hoch fasste oder einen gehör
wir haben es jetzt beim unentschieden
mohn vanille und das werde jetzt hier
ein gefühl schön festhalten damit es
nicht umfällt und das ist jetzt die
füllung für die pralinen
aber jetzt habe ich die füllung hier in
einem spritzbeutel drin schneidet hier
oben die spitze ab und kann jetzt die
hohlkörper damit befüllen direkt bis
fast unter den rand
[Musik]
was ich nicht so fest im griff
und die nächste und falls ihr mal zuviel
füllung eingegeben habt so wie hier
nehmt ihr einfach einen löffel und so
ein bisschen füllung raus und hier
können jetzt die schokolade darüber
gegossen werden und verschlossen werden
ich will jetzt hier noch fertig ist
schon wieder abgedüst ich glaube die
geht zum lukat brunnen und dann müssen
die erstmal ruhen dass die füllung ein
bisschen fest werden kann und werden
dann erst verschlossen
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt temperierte weiße
schokolade und damit erschließt sich
jetzt die pralinen und zwar ein bisschen
mehr overture bzw schokolade drauf geben
denn da kommt jetzt gleich einen bug
papierstreifen drauf und wird klassen
schöner fuß entsteht und die praline
wenn sie dann umgedreht wird auf dem fuß
stehen kann ohne dass ihr weg gerollt
[Musik]
die dürfen jetzt erst mal aushalten und
werden dann fest dekoriert für die
dekoration der mond pralinen verwende
ich jetzt weiße schokolade oder
kuvertüre diese bereits temperiert und
so etwas mond und temporären geht ganz
einfach ihr machte im feld wurde in dem
zwei drittel der schokolade oder
dekorateure erwärmt sie über dem warmen
wasserbad dann geht ihr das restliche
dazu und dann habt ihr die perfekte
verarbeitung temperatur einen kleinen
tipp gibt ihr könnt nämlich
kontrollieren ob die kuvertüre wirklich
perfekt ist taucht einfach einen löffel
in dekorateure legt ihn auf die
arbeitsplatte und dann müsste er
innerhalb von zwei minuten ungefähr
ziehen und schön glänzen und dann könnt
ihr die kuvertüre verwenden ich trug sie
jetzt hier einfach mit der runden seite
rein mit der gabel dran da könnt ihr
zuhause einfach eine gabel nehmen
abstreifen und ich hier auf dem
backpapier setzen dann nehme ich jetzt
einfach das papier was ich eben schon
hatte zum abdecken da braucht ihr kein
frisches und dann spricht gleich mond
drauf bevor die kuvertüre anzieht
[Musik]
sat 1 ist gleich fertig schon wir gehen
direkt zum nächsten sorte das werden die
in berlin
[Musik]
für die himbeere verwenden wir weiße
schokolade kondensmilch
ich habe ich eben der fruchtpüree und
gefriergetrockneten der prüfer vom
prinzip her ist es hier genau das
gleiche kondensmilch oder sahne mit der
schokolade vermischen also eine garage
herstellen und ich habe ich jetzt schon
eine himbeere passte weil wir einfach
hier in der confiserie sind zu hause
würde ich einfach tiefgefrorene
hinnehmen wer schlecht weg und wird die
einfach einkochen lassen bis sie schön
bis es eine paste ist durch ein sieb
streichen und dann habt ihr auch eure
eigene himbeer passte dann gebe ich hier
jetzt die himbeer passte dazu das ist
jetzt eine schöne farbe und wer möchte
kann auch hier gerne etwas hinweg als
dazu geben oder einen likör und die
macht natürlich jetzt auch in einen
spritzbeutel und befüllt die hohlkörper
damit
[Musik]
die berlin werde jetzt auch verschlossen
aber wirklich nur minimal damit sie auch
schöne rund sind also keinen fuß
herstellen gerne noch so ein bisschen
rütteln so verteilt sich die schokolade
schön glatt jetzt lasse ich dir kurz
anziehen und dann werden sie dekoriert
neben pralinen sind jetzt auf west und
ich nehme jetzt einfach handschuhe habe
ich jetzt an einen klecks schokolade in
die hand eine rolle die praline ganz
vorsichtig und jeder auf die kurt höhere
ruhig ein bisschen wärmer sein und dann
hier ins gefriergetrocknete himbeer
pulver reihen etwas schwenken dann nur
noch raus nehmen
[Musik]
für die herz pralinen verwende ich ruby
schokolade und fieber
das ist der klassische lockert 21
anmerken bevor wir jetzt die herz
pralinen machen wir frauen hier drin wir
arbeiten okay da ja und der monat der
schläft im hintergrund ich habe mich die
ganze zeit nur wenn moral hier schläft
willst dann mit ella
[Musik]
die ruby schokolade ist jetzt schon
temperiert genau die gleiche methode
methode und jetzt braucht ihr einfach
nur so kleine pralinen förmchen oder zum
beispiel eiswürfel förmchen berlin 15 da
war natürlich den vorteil dass man auch
eine herzform nehmen kann
hier fühle ich jetzt die schokolade ein
etwa zu einem viertel an etwas rütteln
dabei ist schön glatt wird und die
luftbläschen verschwinden lasse jetzt
fest werden und diese dann noch das
flüssige nougat ströber und dann zeige
ich euch die anderen pralinen in einem
anderen video
[Musik]
ich werde sagen ich war hier doch ganz
schön fleißig habe jetzt hier 12345
sorten pralinen gemacht ich glaube damit
lässt sich die torte und das
tortenbuffet schön dekorieren und die
nehmen wir also mit nach hause morgen
gibts ja erst noch den kinderball ihren
kurs und am samstag also übermorgen wird
die torte fertig gemacht
ich bin schon ganz aufgeregt und ich
hoffe dass den gästen und natürlich auch
dem brautpaar die pralinen schmecken
aber ich glaube schon wenn ich sind
alles für uns drin
[Musik]
sehen wir wieder zu hause heute ist der
tag der hochzeit und es ist gerade
morgens eigentlich wollte ich 38 anfang
wir haben 39 als ich muss mir jetzt echt
beeilen jetzt werden auch die anderen
zwei torten überzogen und zwar werden
die jetzt marmoriert überzogen das heißt
ich habe es hier erst mal weißen von
dort da jetzt einfach 1 7 kilo einmal
david mir schon ausreichen so viel
brauche ich nicht und bei mama effekt
ist es jetzt so ich muss jetzt einmal
dieses mal musste reim machen und dann
kann ich denn von dort im prinzip wieder
einpacken für das nächste für die
nächste torte benutzen und für die
zweite für die obere tor muss ich wieder
ein frisches mama muster machen als ich
nehme jetzt in weißen von don und dann
den an gemischten von dort dieses
dunkelrot der ist schon schön weich
hier habe ich jetzt noch das dunkelrot
und jetzt werde ich ein bisschen
dunkelrot mit etwas weiß schon mal
vermischen damit hellere und dunklere
stellen habe
[Musik]
daraus mache ich jetzt zwei stränge dann
noch das dunkle rot vor einem strang und
ich nochmal ein dunkles rot ich will
jetzt die torte auch nicht zu dunkel
haben das heißt er weiß anteil muss
natürlich höher sein
ich denke das passt das was ich mir kurz
die hände denn ich habe jetzt dunkelrot
geknetet damit es weiß auch schon weiß
bleibt jetzt freue mich das weiß hier
auch erst mal zu einer rolle und ich
hoffe das wird gleich so ein mann muss
für wie es mir vorstelle
die werde ich jetzt einfach so drumherum
schlag das reise jetzt hier noch drüber
jetzt legen zusammen und zwar bloß ein
bisschen jetzt bisschen 10 und falten
und durch das drehen und zwirbeln
entsteht dann dieses gedrehter mama
musste es probieren einfach toll und
dann gucke ich hab's mir gefällt
[Musik]
bevor das hochzeitspaar mag die moderne
torte genauso wie ich
er ist die torte ganz außer puste
hier ist die torte ich habe vorher noch
mal ein bisschen geglättet mit der
restlichen ghana und eine fraktur spray
damit davon doch schön drauf haftet
einsprühen und ich habe jetzt diese
skateboard darunter das heißt ich kann
die torte jetzt wirklich problemlos ohne
torten retter verwenden gucken dass
keine lücke bleibt damit einfach keine
blasen wirft davon dass wir noch eine
blase drin
die sieht man nicht aber ich spüre sie
das gute an seiner maltechnik man sieht
die machen nicht man spürt sie nun
schön glatt streichen und die torte
eindecken
besondere meriten torte sieht man echt
keine macken
dennoch muss ich schon geklettert sein
damit sie auch später keine luftbläschen
wird und reese auch gleich noch um damit
ich nur schöne kannte hier hinbekommen
jetzt ist sie endlich zieht auch schön
aus aber ich hätte gern ein bisschen
eckiger
oh mein gott ist die schwer wie soll ich
die gedreht bekommen 1 ich habe heute
morgen sport gemacht
so habe ich das gemacht und ich krieg
die nicht gedreht 3 1 1 1 2 3 und dann
ist ja leider gedreht ein wenig mehr
helfen und kommt es zum einen weil die
hände so rutschig sind
ich bin ich hier dreht dieser schwer
okay wir machen was ich halte hier und
du drehst du okay kommt dann geht so auf
die seite und trägt so zu mir käme und
123 ich habe keine kraft die schwer wir
müssen ich muss mich später auf die
waage stellen mit der torte und die
torte abwägung gut man kann es auch
zusammenrechnung okay
und jetzt glücklich hier und die seiten
und rückte mit dem teig mit dem fondant
kletter runter und dann bekomme ich die
schöne kannte hin und ihr seht auch
davon dort ist richtig dünn etwa 2 mm
dünn als ihr müsst dann wirklich gar
nicht dick ausrollen schön dünn
ausrollen
dann habt ihr nicht so eine dicke
fettschicht schön dünn und er reist auch
nicht und ihr seht ist richtig schön
elastisch perfekt
okay wir machen was wir da wie eben
was ist mit 1 2 hat motto 123 du drehst
dich halte um mein gott wo haben sie
fast die hände verwurzelt ich hab sie
danke ich glaube diese torte ist einfach
sehr schön geworden
die kommt jetzt in den kühlschrank damit
er von dem bisschen aushärten kann die
kleine torte die obere torte werde ich
genauso überziehen und die krise alleine
gedreht glaube ich ja das kriegen sie
kommt jetzt viel weniger rot rein und
damit die obere trotte etwas mehr weiß
wird
[Musik]
ich könnte auch immer mal die
vorderseite unter webseite anschauen
die seit ihr euch besser gefällt die
nehmt ihr dann hab ich nehme die andere
tor nummer drei ist jetzt auch überzogen
jetzt werde ich die zweite tochter
nehmen also die achteckige und da kommen
jetzt noch die muster drauf und das
nimmt mir glaube ich schon noch ein
bisschen viel zeit also muss ich mich
bei allen die bei mädels sind auch
gleich damit den blumen die blumen
werden hierher geliefert ich hoffe dass
der farbton hat passt denn ich habe
keine blumen bekommen für zum
ausprobieren
gucken wir halt dass es passt die weko
habe ich jetzt hier mode lehmacher
hergestellt dafür verteidigt blüten
passte mit von dort zu gleichen teilen
also eins zu eins und zwar kann ich
jetzt so einem modell im haushalt
stellen die festwirt wie blüten passte
aber eben nicht zu fest von dort bleibt
ja auf der torte auch schön weich so
kann man die torte immer schön
anschneiden blüten pasta herz schön aus
ich kann ganz viele gerade dinge damit
ausschneiden ausstechen und modellieren
und wenn ich beides vermischt habe ich
die perfekte modelliermasse für figuren
zum beispiel und eben auch für die
streifen dicht herstellen werde
freilich geknetet habe ich schon jetzt
wird schön dünn ausgerollt das macht die
entweder mit dem ausruf starb und bäcker
stärke oder einfach mit der nudel wald
holz ein bisschen vor und dann erledigt
die maschine den rest für mich
stärker drei das reicht schon
und theoretisch kann ich jetzt auch die
[Musik]
tagliatelle ich muss es so richtig
aussprechen tagliatelle aufsätze
benutzen dann wird auch gleich
geschnitten
ich mache es aber lieber ich hier jetzt
damit einfach die blüten passte nicht
kringelig wird sondern schön glatt
bleibt und nehme dafür mein easyjet das
lasse ich jetzt so eingestellt weil
detaillierte listen hat deshalb shoprite
ich muss mal kurz abwägen nehme ich
jetzt dieser nämlich das sind die zu
breit für meine torte
wir gehen zum kühlschrank und probierens
aus okay ich hab übrigens und schälchen
mit salz drin stehen
da bleibt einfach der kühlschrank die
feuchtigkeit da noch mit reingeht und
ich hatte also das war so die breite
das glaube ich jetzt gern filigraner
gehabt aber ich probiere jetzt erstmal
aus ja ja kurz halbiert
und stand schon zu schneiden
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt ein ganz sauberes
geschäft hoch und damit könnt ihr gerne
die oberfläche noch ein bisschen ab oder
also die bäcker stärke weg machen und
wenn das so mit dem tuch alleine nicht
geht ein bisschen faktor ins benehmen
und dann schön darüber streichen und
dann bekommt ihr alle reste weg und ganz
auf sein
ihr könnt jetzt theoretisch die streifen
besprühen mit goldener farbe trocknen
lassen und dann an leben das mache ich
jetzt nicht so denn ich will dass die
streifen komplett anliegen ich will dann
das gold nicht verschmieren also werde
ich zuerst die streifen aufkleben und
danach dann mit gold bemalen und ich
schaue jetzt einfach mal ich will sie so
ein bisschen asymmetrisch machen also
jetzt nicht hier entlang
naja ok kleiner plan wechsel ich wäre es
doch so wenn ich werde dich streifen
jetzt komplett gerade hinlegen auf etwas
küchenpapier werte mit gold besprühen
die torte kommt nochmal einen
kühlschrank und wenn die dann ein
bisschen an getrocknet sind ein bisschen
fest sind bekomme ich sie auch ganz
glatt an die torte
so machen wir das wahrgenommen
[Musik]
jetzt da die blumen da sind noch besser
effekt ich heute keinen raus sagte
hätten außerdem die schönen ob gott ich
hoffe der farbton passt
[Musik]
so danke dann probiere ich das gleich
mal aus ich glaube ich habe ein kleines
konstruktions problem das da rein
ich werde es lösen müsste ja ich wusste
der fuß wird zu groß ich wollte hat eine
richtig stabile tortenplatte deswegen
haben jetzt einen richtigen knopf drin
damit beim anschnitt der torte da hat
man echt immer das problem dass die
torten platten so kippeln und deswegen
gibt halt nicht ich gucke jetzt nur dass
ich das da rein kriege irgendwie kriege
ich das für mich wenn ich hatte ihr das
innenmaß gegeben aber ich muss jetzt
sowieso die platte erstmal gesprüht
vielleicht doch noch etwas nach
schneiden ich hab das jetzt so gelöst
ich habe sie abgeschraubt das wird
gleich hier reingestellt der kranz ist
leider etwas größer geworden als
bestellt deswegen gucke ich dass es
gleich rein passt und diese holzplatte
werde ich auch gleich besprühen mit dem
gleichen gold dann ist es einfach
lebensmittelecht und hier habe ich jetzt
noch die buchstaben
ich habe jetzt den start doch nicht rein
gesteckt denn beim reinstecken hast
jetzt einfach immer dass es nicht
verformt das heißt ich habe jetzt die
vorder und die rückseite gold gesprüht
erst die vorderseite trocknen lassen
dann die rückseite und jetzt nehme ich
diese stäbe und habe hier etwas isomalt
geschmolzen also zucker und klebt es
jetzt damit an
[Musik]
das läuft jetzt hier trockene bzw fest
werden
und dann spricht das einfach noch mal
gold an und ist man nicht mehr so krass
sehen
ich werde jetzt hier einfach nur diesen
rand besprühen bzw bepinseln
den rest sieht man sowieso nicht und
stand nicht trocknen lassen und schon
mal die deko machen für die mittlere
torte okay die blume stelle ich zur
seite ich auf die welt jetzt hier nicht
es sind schon so ein bisschen
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt gerade die tortenplatte
auseinandergeschraubt hier drinnen
wieder zusammengeschraubt
jetzt kam mit kranz als ich keine platte
und krams nicht mehr auseinander nehmen
so transport erst später aber daneben
auch in diesem tablet und die torte
transportiere ich extra jetzt sind hier
die teile an getrocknet und ich nehme
jetzt s-bahn kleber der fülle ich jetzt
hier in den teller
jetzt lebe ich hier oben den rand an das
sind 10 cm und ich schneide mir jetzt
einfach immer zu und krebse zu recht
also blieb sie dann an die torte ich
gucke jetzt mal staaten glaube ich nach
oben den rand unten den rand und
dazwischen so park geometrische formen
die sind jetzt auch noch ein bisschen
weich aber eben fest genug damit ich sie
drauf und dran kleben kann perfekt
bisschen kleber bestreichen
auf der rückseite genau das wäre
schlecht und die torte hat ja ja karte
mit dem torten red habe ich ohne eine
schöne kannte und kannst stadt anlegen
geburtstagstorte ohne schutz
hochzeitstorte bisschen perfektion und
für die seiten hier nämlich ein blatt
papier
da passt es der zettel von torres effekt
denn ich kann das jetzt hier nehmen den
goldstreifen drauflegen in dem winkel in
dem ich ihn haben will und dann nicht
haben blatt rechts und links abschneiden
und dann am besten noch markieren fürs
gegenstück ich hier meine erste fläche
habe das papier einfach aneinander
geklebt kann hier das muster legen und
dann schön ankleben
ich mache das immer so jetzt habe ich
hier den einen streifen mir und den
nächsten mache ich so also immer schon
ein schönes zick zack muster aber nicht
geometrisch also nicht symmetrisch
geometrischen aber nicht symmetrisch das
ist später auch wirklich super cool
aussieht
ich zeichne mir das jetzt hier auf und
dann schneide ich alle zu und lädt sie
dann dran
und wenn ihr hier das papier nummeriert
und die torte memoriert dann verwechselt
sie auch nichts da ist abwaschbar
[Musik]
ich mache jetzt schon mal was ich habe
dann komme ich jetzt nicht durcheinander
denn irgendwann sieht man vor lauter
streifen die streifen nicht mehr
das passt nicht bei meiner berechnung
da fehlen zwei zentimeter da kommt es
jetzt her
ich starte jetzt die torte okay okay ich
werde jetzt hier drauf stapeln und dann
werde ich sie aber zum transport wird
herr unternehmen weil das nicht so
unsicher also unterste torte dass sich
die platte gold gemacht habe und damit
die torte jetzt stapeln kann und die
oberen stockwerke nicht in die untere
einsinken muss ich jetzt hier so dippel
reinmachen
die habe ich bereits aus holz
zurechtgeschnitten und ich möchte jetzt
noch mal ab nicht dass ich einen fehler
mache und das sind jetzt einfach buchen
rundhölzer unbehandelt das heißt alles
lebensmittel unbedenklich jetzt hier
aufpassen
wir sind so lange muss dir doch ein
bisschen kürzen
da wird nicht mehr meine art schablone
aus holz
sie sind jetzt so in gleichmäßigen
abständen aber nicht im kreis egal
ok ich werde die torten bild jetzt nicht
miteinander verkleben denn zum transport
nehme ich sie alle wieder auseinander
ok und jetzt hier auch noch bereit ist
über hausbau man kann nicht einfach
stockwerk auf stockwerk setzen sondern
man braucht die säulen dazwischen
die tragenden wände
da dürften 4+ der eine dicke in der
mitte reichen
das wäre die hochzeitstorte und jetzt
fehlen noch die stecker wenn der blumen
kannst es etwas groß geworden aber ich
lasse es jetzt so ist bei euch ist so
die vorderseite dies aber auch schöner
okay die ist auf allen seiten schön l
wie lisa ich muss das jetzt aber ab
damit beides symmetrisch steht
und wenn euch etwas abbricht so wie hier
dann keine sorge ok schloss ist es doch
dran und dann nehmt ihr einfach etwas
isomalt erwärmtes wie silikon also das
hebt super bot dem feld jetzt bombenfest
hat keiner gesehen ja ich würde jetzt
nur noch hier ein kleines geschenk
machen und blumengesteck stoffen ich
meine kleinen reagenzgläser ganz hübsch
aus die noch hier und die hier und die
hier und da nehme ich nämlich einfach
die blumen die kommen hier rein und dann
werde ich das hier so drin versenken
aber das mache ich endlich zeit herrscht
dann setzt es hier ja so ich würde sagen
die torte ist fertig ich werde mich
jetzt fertig machen wir werden die täter
nur fotografieren dann werden wir sie
dorthin transportieren und ich mache
auch noch mit dem handy ein paar
aufnahmen von der hochzeit
ich hoffe euch hat dieses video gefallen
ist so eine torte zu machen ist echt
viel arbeit verkauf und tue ich keine
torten also ich glaube auch wenn man so
eine torte verkaufen würde müsste man
einfach viel zu viel geld verlangen weil
man so viel arbeit rein steckt und ich
glaube jeder der torten backt auch
auftrag backt der weiß das und ich
glaube die beschenkten die wissen meist
glaube ich schon
die torte zu schätzen und die arbeit zu
schätzen deswegen bei mir gibt es keine
auftrags torten ich mache das immer nur
für gute freunde
als geschenk als hochzeitsgeschenk und
jetzt mache das hier fertig und dann
gehen wir jetzt gleich habe die hochzeit
ich hoffe sie schmeckt auch noch so gut
die pralinen sind auch fertig ich dort
noch das buffet und dann fällt glaube
ich ein bisschen die anspannung von mir
ab
[Musik]